you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
more mudslides in California take a look
at this this is in Northern California
around the Fremont area the slide that
took place here blocked a commuter train
track this was yesterday it's the latest
in a long line of incidents caused by
all this rain all these storms President
Biden is expected to visit Central and
Northern California tomorrow Sherry they
have just been hammered over there with
the rain and this is the aftermath yeah
and I think there's still have a lot of
after effects that are yet to come as
that water continues to pour out of the
mountains now as we look at our own
mountains you can see how beautiful it
is with the snow-capped Peaks up there
but this next storm diving out of Canada
is promising to really lower the snow
levels a little much much lower than
they've been lately so we might even see
some neighborhoods with a little snow on
the Rooftops by the time we wake up on
Friday and that would mainly be the West
side up to the Northwest as that system
moves in with some very cold air by
tomorrow night now the rain chances will
begin sooner than that and not looking
for a lot of rain from this system
temperatures today with nice blue skies
and sunshine staying cooler we've got a
lot of 40s out on the West Side 50 at
Mountain's Edge mid 50s for Nellis right
now 43 at Red Rocks started in the 20s
this morning and Kyle Canyons just made
it barely above freezing with teens for
morning lows Ely was below zero this
morning now up to 12. and you can see
still below freezing in Reno and 33 in
Tonopah Death Valley 61-40s for Indian
Springs and Pahrump so it is still quite
chilly out there with just 50 degrees in
Boulder City and low 50s for Mesquite
the winds have calmed down a lot that's
helped as well so we're doing great
rainfall wise officially at almost
two-thirds of an inch of rain so that's
a great and it's just about double where
we should be for the year let's roll the
future cast and I want to show you that
as we get into Thursday cloudy skies and
the chances for rain will come in the
afternoon and by evening with colder air
on the way it is really going to bring
in those lower snow levels we're talking
down to 2500 feet across Clark County
and Southern night County over into
Northwest Arizona so that's where we're
looking for the extremely low snow
levels now not a lot of accumulation we
only May pick up a few inches up at Lee
Canyon so we're talking maybe a dusting
at best in the lower elevations but
again this system is coming out of
Canada already it's cooler in the
Northwest with rain and snow and a lot
of snow in the Rockies and the Plains
today out ahead of our cold system this
is the one from Monday it's pulling up a
lot of instability with thunderstorms
and could see some severe weather with
the possibility of tornadoes these are
already tornado watches in parts of the
Deep South so we'll be watching that
closely 53 for the high today that's
going to be it the winds again calming
down Cloudy Skies by tomorrow and that
chance of showers in the afternoon
possibly mixing with some snow tomorrow
night and then Breezy winds for Friday
that's going to feel much cooler again
and we're keeping below normal
temperatures all through next week John
with mornings near freezing it's going
to be a chilly week all right Sherry
thank you